Okay.
In this video we'll look at how we can
compute marginals in a linear chain
conditional random fields.
Yeah.
So in the previous video,
we've seen how we could compute the
probability of a full sequence of labels y
given x, uh, and uh, uh, to do this,
we just take the exponential of the,
some of the urinary and pairwise factors
and then we have to divide by this
partition function.
In a previous video,
we've seen how we can actually compute
this partition function efficiently,
even though it involves a lot of nested
sums over other potential labels at each
physician by computing, uh, an
Alpha table or a bed, a table,
we could actually, uh,
through a dynamic program,
get a very efficient procedure
for that is not exponential.
The size of the sequence for
computing the partition. A function.
Yeah.
So, uh, to do this, like I said,
we had to precompute a table of a Noah
that we call alpha or a pre a table that
we call better for a where each
essentially computes the summation of the
exponentiate good luck
factors that involves, um,
all of the labels to either the left of
a given position or to the right of a
given position. And so now let's
assume again that we've done this,
a computation of either the
alpha. I actually have both
the Alpha and Beta table.
What we'll see now is an expression
for how to compute marginals,
uh, marginal probability over
the sequence. So for instance,
the probability of a single label
at a specific position, Kay.
And,
uh,
what we'll see is that this expression
also requires the Alpha and Beta values.
And specifically we'll assume that we're
using the stable implementation of the
often better table where we actually
have a table that contains the Lug Alpha
and the lug better, uh,
values. And this is again,
very important to actually implement
that variant of the computation or the
Alpha and Beta tables to get something
that's a numerically more stable.
So now here we're interested
in computing. Um, uh,
we'll and we'll see to the particular
marginals the marginal over a specific
position.
So the probability of a single label
in the sequence at a given position,
k or the pairwise,
uh,
they probably have a pair of
labels at a position k again,
so that's the first look at this one. The
marginal property over single position.
Well again, we'll use the Alpha and Beta
tables. So remember that the Alpha table,
uh, essentially gives us the
uh, value of the luck of the,
some of the exponentiate
good luck factors for uh,
all the potential labels to
the left of a given position.
And the better gives us a
similar computation before
the log of the psalms or
the lug better table's going
to give us the log of the,
some of the exponentiate it a urinary
and pairwise potentials to the write ups
of given position.
Now if we want to Compute p
of y k position k given x,
well that would correspond to the sum
over [inaudible] and the sum over why to
up to the sum over y came on this one
than the sum over y k plus one up to the
sum over y capital gain
of p of y where why here would be in bold.
That would be the whole sequence
given the sequence of inputs. Okay,
so that's just marginalization and
operation that we know from probability
theory gives us.
Now the probability over just a y k at
the specific position came and we've seen
that the lug alpha value and the lug
better value actually gives us these
summations.
So Lug Alpha value performs the summation
over the labels from position one to
uh,
came on a swan and the lug bed attire
value gives us the lug summation of uh,
the value of the label or position.
K plus one up to a y came.
So actually specifically,
uh,
this sum here is going to correspond
to the Alpha came on this one value.
So, uh, remember this index
tells us, uh, from y one, two,
why came on a swan that, uh, it gives a,
that this bottle corresponds
to the summation of why one,
up to why came on this one.
And then similarly, uh,
this sum here with Chris
Bond to a better k plus one,
uh, that is the k plus one wins
that we've summed from, uh,
y capital k two Y K plus one.
So,
uh,
I won't go into detail as
to how we obtained this
expression or leave that as an
exercise, but we can show that
the property of yk given, uh,
the whole sequence x is
just the exponential of the
unitary factor at a position
case.
Our preference for whether we like seeing
the specific value of Y K at position
k plus,
well the Lug Alpha values and lug
better values for where we assume that,
uh, the label, that position case
taking the value. Why K here and here?
So these are the sons that
are conditioned on, uh,
the Kl label being equals
to being called to y k. Uh,
and same thing here and now
together probably distribution. Uh,
we need,
uh,
to make sure that this is normalized
so we can just normalize the numerator.
It turns out. And so we're
summing over all potential values,
which I'm getting to a name.
Why Prime K of the numerator?
So the exponential of, uh,
the urinary factor for, uh,
the position gay if we
assume the labeled takes,
why prime Kate as a value and then the
summation of everything to the left,
assuming why prime, assuming the KF
label, it takes value of our prime gay.
And in the summation to
the, uh, to the left,
the submission to the left submission
to the right, assuming that, uh,
the kids labeled takes value.
Y Prime King.
So actually this you can think of as just
doing the softmax non linearity on the
vectors of this term here.
The luck factor plus the log
Alpha luck, better values. And,
um, so, uh, you know,
the key to understanding why this makes
sense is that the log alpha and the lug
better values give us the sums over the
everything to the left and everything to
the right,
which is a sum we have to perform.
If we want to marginalize
out these value, uh, these,
these labels and get the probability
for only a single position.
And similarly using the same reasoning
if you want the probability of the
[inaudible] label and the k plus
one year label taking value,
why k and why k plus one,
then we'll have a,
that expression be the exponential
of the unitary factor for position k.
Also the urinary factor for position
k plus one plus the pairwise factor,
uh,
that expresses a preference between
the label position k and k plus one.
And then plus, while the summation
of everything that's to the left.
So from position one, two k minus one, and
then everything's, that's to the right.
So from position Cape Plus to
a till the end until uh, uh,
position capital king. And again,
to have this be a valid probability,
we need to divide by the summation over
all the values that the label could
take.
And they,
Cape Plus one yet labeled could take of
the exponential of essentially exactly
the same term. So we see the exponential
term here is exactly this term.
I've just replaced why gay by
y Prime K, uh, which is uh,
and y and y k plus one by y
prime keep plus one. So again,
this is also similar to
a soft max operation,
but this would be a soft Max
especial softmax over, uh,
if you want the matrix of
activations for all values of a y,
K and why k plus one for this,
the sons of urinary a pairwise
and log out the lug better terms.
All right,
so this is how you compute a marginals
in the conditional random fields.
And the reason I explained this now is
that particular we'll want to use this,
uh, to make a prediction, uh, that we, uh,
one procedure for performing
classification of each
and each position is going
to be to use this.
And we also use both of these marginals
in their linear chain conditional random
fields. Uh, when we'll want to
train the conditional random fields,
which is going to be the
topic of, uh, the, uh,
videos for the following week.